all right this is uh from The Blaze says
a former Olympian delivered an
eye-opening remark comparing
professional sports contracts to slavery
during an appearance on ESPN's new
series hosted by anti-racist ibram X
kendi ESPN gave kendi his own series
titled skin in the game which delves
into and challenges racism in the Sports
World and will reveal how pervasive
racism is in sports while challenging
the thoughts and systems of various
governing bodies the five episode series
features episodes subtitled how do
athletes play a role in social change
are black women athletes carrying the
weight of the
world uh no the answer I can answer that
I I haven't even watched the
episode and I can already tell you no
black women athletes are not carrying
the weight of the world um what is the
cost of race
norming and what is the impact of racist
ideas in sports
media the first episode aired on
September 20th in which Kendy takes a
look at black athletes who use public
platforms to protest Injustice and what
it cost to speak up um and during this
conversation there was a or during this
episode there was a conversation about
sports contracts and why Sports
contracts are tantamount to slavery
we've heard similar ideas already from
from Colin Kaepernick who infamously uh
declared in a Netflix
special that NFL owners are are are
slave owners you know and NFL players
are basically slaves out in the out in
the cotton field um and then turned
around and this season was trying
desperately to get back on the
plantation out into the cotton field
again even though he just said it was
like it's like slavery he wanted to be
in the NFL again anyway um so similar
idea let's watch
this the contracts you know are the new
slave chains right so you know you have
to sign this contract and sign this
document and sign this document it's
like you're binded to this and then if
you break that that's your livelihood
that's your life so we the New Slaves
athletes are literally the New Slaves
because we need this our families our
friends depend on this contract to
eat
um yeah athletes are the New Slaves she
says and uh I mean first of all not that
not that it matters to anyone but it's
just amazing to see this again this is
an ESPN special um and the whole special
the you know that they gave to ebx
kendi and the whole thing is just
apparently all about athletes
complaining about their persecuted lives
and all the racism that they suffer um
this is appealing to nobody like who is
actually going to sit down that's what I
want I want to know what the actual like
how many actual real world viewers is
this series getting because I I I find
it hard to believe that that if it's if
they tell it's a number above zero I'm
not going to believe
it what actual person is going to sit
that and that's one thing you watch the
clip to make fun of it
sure but who's gonna sit there and say
oh yeah I I gotta not only do I have to
watch one I gotta watch all five I gotta
watch five hours of
this this appeals to no nobody wants to
see this even the people who are
ideologically aligned they don't want
they're actually going to sit and watch
that because even most of them know on
some level how absurd it is
so this is ESPN they they are just
determined to destroy
themselves you know they get woker and
woker by the
year and they lose audience and they
lose ratings and uh they're Al like
needlessly
alienating whole swaths of Their
audience and they don't they don't stop
this get keeps just gets worse and
worse um they're determined to destroy
themselves which is fine you know it's
like
it's it's we're not going to the world
won't be missing them at all but um it
is amazing to
see
um and of course what we're actually
seeing here is uh you know it's if
you're on the left as we've talked about
so many times this is that victimhood
pathology and I think part of what it is
is like they they
associate to them as we know the the
victimhood hierarchy
and uh all power comes from your
victimhood it comes from the kind of
emotional blackmail that you can
wield um by cashing in your your
victimhood
chips and so victimhood is
empowering
and so no matter what happens in their
lives they still are grasping for that
victimhood they they don't know how to
be satisfied in life they don't know how
to be happy
you know if they were if you're a
professional
athlete which by the way if you're a
professional athlete to your credit it
means that you've worked very very hard
to perfect your craft you're very very
good at what you do matter what matter
what sport you're in balance of nature
fruits and veggies are a great way to
make sure you're getting essential
nutritional ingredients every single day
balance of nature uses an advanced cold
vacuum process to preserve the vitamins
minerals and phytonutrients of the
fruits and vegetables they use the
capsules are whole food supplements with
no additives fillers extracts synthetic
pesticides or added sugar the only thing
in their capsule is pure fruit and
vegetables balance of nature sent a
bunch of their products down to the
studio for my team to try and we all
love them with balance of nature I get
the nutrition of over 10 servings of
fruit and vegetables and just a few easy
to swallow capsules this makes my crazy
schedule so much more manageable the
matter what my day looks like I start
each morning with my balance of nature
fruits and veggies when you're
disciplined enough to take care of your
health you reap all kinds of benefits
your body will thank you go to Balan
nature.com use promo code Walsh for 35%
off your first order as a preferred
customer that's balance of nature.com
promo code wall for 35% off your first
preferred order since the overturning of
roie way the left has lost their minds
making abortion their official Sacrament
meanwhile pro-life efforts which are now
more than important than ever are
booming as one of the largest pro-life
organizations in the world no one is in
a better position than 40 Days for life
to end abortion state by state 40 Days
for life is changing hearts and Minds in
the most blue pro-abortion States
they've had a record number of of
locations uh since row was overturned
and they grew in both volunteers and
locations with a million Volunteers in
1500 cities 40 Days for life holds
peaceful vigils outside abortion
facilities you can help their volunteers
fight the ongoing legal battles to
protect free speech for their volunteers
by giving a tax deductible gift of any
amount to 40 days forlife.com that's 40
days forlife.com
in most sports especially if it's the
major sports you're making a lot of
money doing
it and so you think you would think if
you yeah if you're a normal person you
would think just
psychologically you would want to say to
yourself well wow you know I worked
really hard for this and um and I've
made it to this point made it to the
Mountaintop this is great I'm so
grateful for
this I'm I'm I'm
happy but they don't they don't know how
to be happy or to be
satisfied no matter where they end up in
life they still are are grasping at that
victimhood so that even now a
multi-million dollar contract that they
choose to sign is uh is it's not just
they're not just saying that it's
like similar to slavery they're saying
it is slavery notice that they're saying
that this is slavery if You' like to see
what else I have to say you can access
my full show by going to dailywire.com
or by going to the Matt wall Show
Twitter page hope to see you there godp
speed